hello and welcome to this video playing
build button
buta bottom ok nazi going to do him
Benoni
this should not work
I just wonder why
I mean if I was probably just better for
wine but is that the real reputation of
the whole thing we should be fine
[Music]
Jim it's tough to say how this how this
is refuted exactly I mean you can
totally refute it it's quite clear but
how do you do this if five men she for
this is probably very good but okay
taking too long yeah this is what I saw
quickly as something that should be good
but I have I tried to find something
better I didn't succeed in this task but
maybe this is this is what this is this
is good enough that same 23 that's the
6n that could no there's no D 6 D 6
great he might play some basic stuff
okay no ching-ching
Bishop d3 I go Bishop and six Queen
takes Queen c3 Knight takes B takes and
he just cannot class or I mean I don't
see how it's surviving this
there should be two there is Bishop b7
winning in the house
he has to take nap night takes a 6-1
what else
I mean it's crap but it hits that's what
is what happens if you play a5 b5 Knight
a 6 you have to do it what what else I'm
threatening we should be 7 him
I have no clue what's what he's thinking
about it just has to take it or is he
disconnected or something doesn't look
like any technical issue okay that that
I discarded right away like that can
never work so now I'm rocky one org d1 I
would absolutely let's start with this
threatening Bishop g7 Wow okay and I was
very quick-witted it was beyond
salvation and I'm not quite sure how you
can play b5 it's just I can never work
as you just cannot work the idea is
well-known for example if you Castle
which is not good you to e5 but okay
let's say you Castle and I go here then
b5 is kind of playable yeah but just
like that that won't work
I wasn't sure again how to refute it if
fives made me best I was also thinking
about Bishop takes because here he has
not castled so I was thinking this this
this and now ideas like Bishop d2 Queen
b5
Bishop c3 but I didn't think it was so
clear I mean I cannot Castle in fact it
it's not good at all but this is a
difference to the other line so it's
what I checked so if 594 yeah here I
probably Bishop b5 looked best yeah
there should be five Knight takes and
then Queen e2 even now Bishop h6 is also
strong so probably it was the best line
and is close to you feeling what black
does young Queen d3 Bishop a6
yeah and now castling is stronger stem
yeah I suspected you because even take
on a six-night takes he's got night
before so I can better Castle and ask
him okay what is your move and black
really has no no good move available
like this is bad
he simply can never get the King out and
if I get rookie one and this tech yeah
he took he took him and now push up a
six now it's I thought Knight takes you
have to play give this and then pawn
takes it is it's terrible really
this Queens also tied to the night and
I'm just threatening to to win against
the king who he won in d6 moves like
that yeah I took with the Queen Queen
takes f6 rook e1 it's kind of normal now
king f7 I thought I didn't see that c5
was hanging I would have played rook 81
with the idea to play d6 at the right
moment yeah this and I thought exactly
that was the line that I was thinking
and now threatening Bishop f4 this is
just I want to say long-term problem but
probably not so long-term it probably
will get mated okay guys thanks for
watching